[Music]
[Applause]
let me bring in Dan orlovski it's a busy
man Dan you can catch him on NFL live
weekdays at four Eastern Marcus Spears
Mina kimes Ryan Clark Laura Rutledge and
uh of course Monday Night Football as
well Dan thanks for joining us here if
it's always an honor if I said who's
going further farther this year the Rams
are the Niners does recency bias play a
role
no because the better of those teams in
this moment is San Francisco
the team that is more capable of making
a deeper run is the Rams
um you know everyone's going to talk
about last night rightfully so in the
dominant performance by San Francisco
defensively the Rams were down four of
their top six offensive linemen I would
hope San Francisco would dominate the
line of scrimmage given that they're one
of the best defenses in the NFL
um the Rams do have some issues up front
and they've got to get healthy and
better there there's a reason why they
they play Under Center so much right now
and and try to run the ball and play
action because they're trying to protect
their offensive line do I think that
Odell Beckham is coming to the Los
Angeles Rams at some point this year I
do that is needed right now Alan
Robinson cannot get open you know so
you'll hear everybody today my boy
Marcus Spears is saying it they Gotta
Throw to someone else other than Cooper
cut well you go play quarterback and do
it you know that sounds good yes but
when you got two seconds to get the ball
to your hands you're gonna go to the guy
that you feel is proving I can get open
so they got to get healthy up front they
gotta get Odell back
um because I those are two needed pieces
San Francisco no one has questioned can
they be good the thing with Trey was man
can Trey make them even better can he do
things offensively that Jimmy cannot so
um
good football team one of the defenses
in the NFL I would not want to play or
coach against right now is San Francisco
um but the the difference in the
quarterbacking is very real and the Rams
can play in a couple different styles
San Francisco has to play in one very
specific one
I thought San Francisco had the makeup
to be a better team because it felt like
it was a more balanced team they run the
football good offensive line you got a
couple of Playmakers Kittle and Debo and
it really comes down to Jimmy G can
Jimmy G manage a game Stafford throws a
lot of picks
um and and you know you're going to
start forcing you know what did Cooper
cup have 18 targets he had 14 catches
but really nothing that was dangerous
there the running game was not there
because of the offensive line but I just
wonder about the offense with the Rams
more than I do the Niners offense which
sounds crazy yeah and that's fair I
don't have necessarily the wonders of
the Rams right now the Rams and I've
kind of said this about a couple teams
they're they don't have the people to be
who they are right now so when that
happens okay who can we be this week you
know and I think that Sean is trying to
figure out all right this week because
he's sitting down we got to play San
Francisco 49 liners and I got three
backup offensive linemen and what what
it always starts again you block how can
you block them all right so what can we
be this week and until they get healthy
up front this is very similar to the
thoughts on like Tampa Bay as well until
they get really healthy it's very
difficult to say who they can be now if
they don't get healthy Dan they got no
shot that's a real thing yeah but I I
don't believe that their offensive line
is going to be out for the length of the
season
do they win
with Garoppolo or is he with
okay they don't win because of Jimmy
okay all right yeah they win with I know
that we love to say you know all they
all he does is win like that Depot catch
I mean really that's it the pass was not
good and Debo made everybody miss that
could have been a pick six there but
there's also something to be said for
winning with I mean there's there's
there's five or six guys that you win
because of and then there is another you
know eight to ten that you win with so
there is something to be said for we win
a lot of games with this guy that
doesn't mean that if he's out we will
win a lot of games with just anybody
else but the San Francisco 49ers would
win a lot of games with Kirk Cousins
they would win a lot of games with
um I'm trying to think like another
relatively solid quarterback that you
sit there and go Derek Carr they'd win a
lot of games with Derek Carr so it's not
like Jimmy using nobody but Kyle's
proven in his track record he wins a lot
of games with good quarterbacks we're
talking to Dan orlovsky of the
mothership uh September I've coined that
trademarked it who was your September VP
in the NFL Lamar okay Lamar Jackson he
you know candidly he was my pick in the
preseason you know up until last week's
game in a little bit of the second half
fall off
he was the number one threat passing
quarterback in the NFL he was a top five
rusher he had counted for 90 percent of
their offense it was ridiculous credit
Josh Allen to Buffalo for their comeback
but what Lamar is doing and being asked
to do is is still tremendous
um he's covering up for a defense it's
not very good he's covering up for a run
game right now that's not great in
Baltimore
um I would say I you know me I can't
always just give you one Patrick is
absolutely in that conversation you know
it it the the way that Patrick right now
is playing is you know it's as good as
he's played in his MVP year and the
stuff that he is capable of doing now
with their offensive line a special
um and I was thinking about this
question I like the third person I would
put in there is Micah Parsons
I really would the Dallas's defense is
it's the most I said this on get up
yesterday Dallas has the most reliable
play in all of football and that is a
passing down situation if you are in an
obvious past situation and because of
Micah you I honestly you have no shop
you have no shot against that defense
so those three and uh and now you know
Cooper Rush is your quarterback they'll
probably try to trade Dak Prescott right
or he's going to be yeah that's you know
what let's instead of going with the guy
that we gave 140 million dollars to
let's go with the guy that wasn't even
on our active roster five days before
game one let's do that but I did point
this out the last two weeks if Dak put
up the numbers that Cooper Rush did we'd
go ah Dak didn't have a great game I
mean kind of pedestrian he had one
touchdown pass and threw for 207 yards
or something Cooper Rush were like damn
get ready for Canton and this guy's
unbelievable
expectation breeds disappointment yeah I
mean that's a the expectations were I
mean I was one of those people when Jack
went down I was like your season's done
yeah if you don't get a quarterback you
know and I honestly felt that way
because Cooper rushed five years in he
was on practice squad no one's claiming
you know you're sitting there this
offensive Line's Not Gonna Be Good
Michael Michael Gallup won't be back
cities not proven and I you know I kind
of think one of the things that's
interesting about Dallas is everybody
has to learn from this situation in
Dallas not just Dak everyone and there's
a difference between identity and
philosophy you know for Dallas you're
you're your philosophy should not change
you know when Dak comes back our
philosophy should be well we're more
than Dak Prescott our offensive line can
be good on the Run game and we don't
have to try to hey we got to be the
number one scoring offense in the NFL
um our identity can be philosophically
that hey as long as our defense isn't
put in really bad situations we're not
going to give games away and you know
during the regular season that's a
really good way to build yourself up for
the playoffs
I've been on my soapbox talking about
the Tua situation wanting to know even
if it's not a concussion if you get up
and you stumble like that a couple times
you have to be held up just the eye test
said you shouldn't be back in a football
game you just you shouldn't be and I use
the analogy that a former quarterback
gave me if I was at a party at your
house and I got up and I did that would
you let me drive home and the answer is
no you would not right
um but they're they're sticking with
that was a back injury and then this was
a concussion and now he's not playing
this week
so where do you stand with and then they
fire the independent neurologist here
like somebody had to pay a price so the
media people like me would go away like
hey we took care of it no problem and
then Cameron Bright
has a concussion on Sunday night
I said it was his shoulder he goes back
into the game
yeah like I think you know obviously
this has been a really good not good
conversation it's been a really
interesting one I was on TV the day
after the two of stuff so I saw the tour
play and he goes down and I've I've had
that before personally I've watched my
teammates do and you go yup concussion
and then it comes out well in the
broadcast back I don't know if it's not
a back injury or not like my my my
natural history tells me that looks like
a head thing but I've I also have seen
people with debilitating back issues
like go down like that you know so I I
went to school for 17 years for me to
graduate college I don't know so yeah
but he grabbed his head sure but but I
like again my natural thought was okay
that's concussion but then when the
report comes out back I I'm at I was at
the point Dan where I was like you know
what there has been such a conversation
around head injuries and football for 10
plus years now and the NFL has done such
a good job of putting this at the
Forefront that I have no reason not to
trust that situation like I have no
reason to sit there and go absolutely
not the Dolphins are lying or that
independent neurologist there's no way
that they know what they're doing again
me or the in independent neurologist who
do I believe can handle the situation
better but the other side has lied to us
before Dan they deceived us before but
when when was the last time that we feel
like the NFL deceived us when it came to
this was it two years ago or was it 15
years ago 20 years ago right well they
did have a settlement where they paid
out a billion dollars and sure but you
know what I'm saying because I had that
this kind of this new era mindset of it
of man the lawsuits of the pastors no
and I even said on get up like we're
past the point of players being like no
no I'm good you know you're no longer
allowed to do that because if you're 24
and you took a hit like Tua and you're
trying to stay with the Lions and play
there's no shots
correct yes you're gonna lie correct but
the grown-up has to assess that and say
he's got he's in trouble even if it's a
back injury and and I I can't put him
back in totally until and that's where
you know like absolutely I would have
lied about that
um and the grown-up but I had given the
assumption that the grown-up would
handle it the right the right way at at
least in their in their non-biased
medical profession
um obviously it certainly feels like
that was something with his head on that
Sunday and then the Thursday night
happens the the most interesting part
about it now for me is because
everyone's like well even if they're
wobbly they gotta get out of the game
and they shouldn't be allowed in the
game and my pushback is this Dan like
because I think that's very easy for all
of us to sit here and say what happens
if that's the AFC title
you know it's like what happens when
when Mahomes got hurt a couple of years
ago and it was his knee
now I can't take him out if it's his
knee
right right so what happens if like what
happens if I take this massive shot as a
quarterback and I get hit to the ground
and really it's I think I might have
just broke a rib or something like that
and my first thing is like oh my gosh
that you know and then we'll grabs his
head it's just I don't believe that
there's this perfect black and white
answer for it air on the side of caution
for sure
but again there's this also very real
reality of when the stakes are at the
absolute highest
do we still feel that same way about
those situations I know I know I think
it's fair uh in the final 30 seconds
watching Green Bay and Tampa Bay feels
like this is who Green Bay is going to
be this season yep Tampa Bay can still
be better
you know when they get everybody back or
get healthier
um so higher ceiling Green Bay or Tampa
Bay I say Green Bay oh really is the
second most explosive offense in the NFL
right now and they've got rookie
receivers having a big impact those kids
are only going to get better I think
it's hard for me to sit here and believe
that Tampa is going to get healthier
that's one of the hardest things in the
league that usually get less healthy as
the season goes still really good but I
I I'm really high on Green Bay right now
after the first month uh we love having
you on every time UConn wins UConn
football and I I see it yeah it looks
like you just Dynasty did you just buy
that it looks like it's got a tag
nobody dominates Fresno State like you
guys do hey they can't come across
country
great to talk to you thanks buddy thank
you man that's Dan orlovsky of the
Mothership